one of the
distinct features of this operation has
been that
israel has targeted a number of
high-rise buildings in gaza
the israeli military is using
tanks and artillery fire unmanned drones
and other sophisticated weapons
the palestinian militants are firing
mainly unguided rockets
into israel
so there's been quite a wide path of
destruction
on the civilian infrastructure and
civilian homes in gaza
[Music]
two specific towers that house a number
of media organizations
including one that housed both the
associated press and
al jazeera the israelis gave warning
to the owner of the building to evacuate
the building
and journalists from the ap and these
other organizations had to
flee for their lives before it was
demolished the israelis have said that
there were hamas military intelligence
using
some offices in this building both the
ap
and other organizations have said that
they had no evidence that that
was the case
gaza is a territorially the size of
washington dc but with a population
about
three times the size of dc and so
you can imagine the difficulty of trying
to separate civilians from anything you
might be
trying to bomb in gaza
[Music]
the israeli military says that what it's
been targeting
is a system of tunnels used by
palestinian militants that is underneath
the neighborhoods of the gaza strip
as well as rocket construction
facilities
and militant leaders that it says are
responsible for
these rocket attacks from gaza into
israel
what we've found in our reporting is
that a lot of
civilians have died in these attacks
israel said that they were targeting a
tunnel and that
the collapse of the building was an
accidental result of that
attack it's a situation where there are
many people
the vast majority of them civilians who
are scared for their lives and they have
nowhere to run because they live in a
territory that's been cut off from the
outside world
and it's a very dense urban center
[Music]
they are reaching further into israeli
territory attacking tel aviv and
jerusalem
israelis will tell you that they are
constantly hearing
sirens that force them to run to their
bomb shelters
palestinian militants they are using
deadly weapons there's no doubt about
that
but they are at a disadvantage when it
comes to
fighting israel which is simply a much
more powerful military
israel has a missile defense system
called the iron dome
which has intercepted they say about 90
of rockets that have reached israeli
territory
you